Google cloud next 2017 hosted a hundred
percent of your daily recommended intake
of torques detailing the future of cloud
if you didn't get a chance to catch the
session using Google Apps Script to
automate G suite then stay tuned because
here's the recap Apps Script is a
service JavaScript runtime for G suite
automation extension and integration
which is a fancy way of saying that your
script runs when you need it to without
you needing to provision servers for it
to run on app script code is written in
JavaScript and it runs within a sandbox
interpreter that provides access to our
API and services most importantly Apps
Script make it's extremely easy to
enhance G suite to meet your business
needs for example you can use Apps
Script to help you do things like
automate document approval simplify and
create dashboards user provisioning and
pretty much everything in between there
are a number of entry points for you to
start using a script within your
organization the first is Docs sheets
and the forms script editor we call
scripts created this way container-bound
scripts are just bound scripts you can
easily create simple trigger functions
that respond to changes on the document
for example on open or on edit within
sheets you can create custom functions
that work just like the built-in
functions but implemented as JavaScript
in your script now if you're looking for
a script that attaches to a document
like a bound script but could be
attached to many different documents
you're probably looking for an add-on
the second entry point is through the
cloud IDE at script.google.com this is
ideal for scripts that aren't tied to a
particular document that could include
anything from one-off utility scripts to
web app scripts and add-ons you can
think of these as bound scripts that can
be bound to any document by any user who
installs it now the final two entry
points are a little bit more specialized
you can build AdWords scripts to
automate your AdWords campaigns or use
scripts with an app maker which is
currently still in beta in each case the
built-in app scripts api provide access
to other Google or GC PAP is as advanced
services simplified Ajax and stack
driver integration if you'd like to know
more about what's possible with Apps
scripts in G suite and see some live
coding examples of how simple it is to
implement check out the full
in video and if you want more recaps on
great next content make sure to check
out the rest of our playlist and don't
forget the Google cloud summit coming
soon to a city near you
[Music]